[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi
le rendez vous de l'emploi et de la
formation professionnelle ce mois ci on
va parler d'éco mobilité de mobilité
verte un secteur en forte croissance
tout de suite
le sommaire de cette édition c'est un
marché en pleine expansion
l'installation des bornes de recharge
pour les véhicules électriques
la spécialité de bouygues énergie et
services entreprises implantées sur
saint quentin en yvelines découverte des
métiers autour de cette filière elle
vient de s'installer à coignières
l'entreprise caroit transforme les
moteurs thermiques en moteurs
électriques sur les véhicules lourds
cette société recherche de nouveaux
collaborateurs durant l'année 2020 enfin
focus sur l'estacade son offre de
formation en lien avec l'éco mobilité
l'école d'ingénieurs implantée à
montigny le bretonneux développe ces
questions dans chacune de ces filières
les explications dans ce numéro un
chiffre pour commencer plus de 27 mille
bornes de recharge ouvert au public en
octobre 2019 c'est le chiffre donné par
le ministère de la transition écologique
et solidaire
le marché des bornes destinées aux
véhicules électriques se développent une
conjoncture ressenti au sein de bouygues
énergie et services c'est la filiale de
bouygues construction elle installe et
gère ce type d'infrastructure un secteur
en besoins de recrutement découvert des
différentes activités sur un montage de
xavier jaglin l'installation de bornes
de recharge de véhicules électriques
c'est l'une des spécialités du site
bouygues énergie et services de plaisir
et nous sommes avec charles brisard
bonjour bonjour vous êtes chargé
d'affaires sur cet établissement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le présenter
ce site alors ici vous êtes sur le
centre de plaisir
on accueille une quarantaine de
compagnons de chef d'équipé de fonctions
supports dont je fais partie le chargé
d'affaires les rh et également les
contrôleurs de gestion
on travaille principalement sur les
infrastructures extérieures donc on
parle ici de candélabres de
signalisation lumineuse tricolore est
également de bornes de recharge pour
véhicules électriques
quels sont les différents métiers qu'on
retrouve sur ce site alors ici vous avez
principalement des électriciens et des
terrassiers qui participent tous les
jours à l'illumination des villes et la
recharge des véhicules électriques par
les installations et la maintenance
alors aujourd'hui on va voir
l'installation d'une borne de recharge
de véhicules électriques dans quelques
minutes on va partir à noisy le roi
comment évolue cette activité autour de
ce type d'infrastructure alors pour nous
c'est une activité très porteuse assez
récente même si le groupe bi énergie et
services elles aussi impliquent depuis
plus de neuf ans maintenant
la croissance du nombre de bornes de
recharge installée est exponentielle au
même titre que celle des véhicules et le
tout en français dans les yvelines c'est
une activité aussi porteuse c'est une
activité porteuse pour nous pour le
centre de plaisir principalement dans un
stade actuellement une centaine sur
l'année 2019 combien de personnes
travaillent autour de ce type
d'infrastructure est ce que ce sont les
mêmes qui installe d'autres dispositifs
de d'electric des lampadaires ou
d'autres activités que que vous
installez alors les compagnons qui
travaillent ici ainsi que les chefs
d'equipe sont formés sur les gestes
électrique de tout type
ils sont susceptibles de travailler sur
d'éclairage public également des bornes
de recharge
même si ce matériel est un petit peu
spécifique par sa programmation
on a des compagnons qui sont formés
uniquement la programmation et d'autres
qui ont des activités diverses quelle
formation ils ont suivi quels sont les
différents types de de formation d'école
qu'on peut intégrer pour ensuite
travailler chez vous alors on accueille
tout type de profil pour l'installation
des bornes des personnes qui sont en
apprentissage chez nous où des gens qui
sont qui ont suivi un cursus un peu plus
long à la fois des monteurs électriciens
donc d une formation d'électricien ou
des électrotechnicien pour la
programmation par exemple vous l'avez
dire il ya une installation de plus en
plus importante de ce type de d'outils
de type d'infrastructure comment vous
adaptez aussi en terme de main d'homme
je suppose que vous recherchez beaucoup
de personnel alors effectivement c'est
des métiers nouveaux pour nous on a des
besoins assez important aussi bien sur
les bornes de recharge mais aussi sur
les smart city en général parce que
c'est des métiers porteurs et qui nous
demande beaucoup de connaissances on
recrute pas mal de deux compagnons de
chef d'équipé électricien
électrotechnicien pour l'implantation ce
type de matériel quel type de profil
vous recherchez plutôt des personnes
expérimentées ou des jeunes qui sortent
d'écoles on cherche plutôt des jeunes
effectivement parce que pour des sujets
d'appétence pour les sujets électronique
et de programmation d'informatique
on a on a plus de facilité à former ce
type de personnes sur les métiers des
infrastructures de recharge bon c'est le
moment on va aller sur le chantier allez
on y va
[Musique]
et nous voilà sur le chantier avec
julien ardouin et sébastien bullard deux
techniciens de bouygues énergie et
services ils sont actuellement en train
de poser une borne de recharge de
véhicules électriques on va voir comment
ça se passe tout de suite
[Musique]
je viens voir bonjour bonjour vous avez
32 ans vous ça fait dix ans que vous
travaillez pour bouygues et énergie et
services
qu'est-ce que vous êtes actuellement en
train de faire on est en train de poser
une bande d'une borne de recharge
électrique pour les véhicules
électriques
donc on est en train de mettre quatre
tiges quatre tiges à frapper dans un
béton qui a déjà été a déjà été fait par
un an par un autre service pour la
cellule au sol c'est une activité de
plus en plus fréquentes dans votre
quotidien
depuis une petite année oui sur l'
agence de plaisir on en pose de plus en
plus quelle formation vous avez fait
pour faire ce métier j'ai fait un bep
électrotechnique sur versailles et un
bac pro sur montmorillon à côté de
poitiers
vu que c'est une activité de plus en
plus croissante c'est un secteur qui
embauche et vous avez aussi je suppose
des personnes en apprentissage les
personnes que vous formez aussi la
bouille énergie et services
oui je suis moi-même tuteur dans la
société
d'un jeune en apprentis et du coup la
société oui embauche pour la cause des
bornes et aussi pour d'autres pour
d'autres activités au sein de la société
qu'est ce qui vous reste à faire là
maintenant la mise à niveau de la borne
et puis après raccorder la mise à la
terre de la bande
et puis après elle sera opérationnelle
les personnes pourront venir
dans un deuxième temps inédit en or à la
mettre sous tension et
au préalable la borne a été programmé
pour que
au sein de la supervision derrière la
cuisse est juste sur internet et qui
puisse la gérer entre guillemets jules
hardouin merci beaucoup et justement la
partie programmation la partie
supervision on y va tout de suite sur
saint quentin en yvelines dans
l'immeuble future a3
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on opère 5254 points de
charge ce qui fait plus de 2300 bornes
ce qu'une borne souvent il ya deux
points de charge
actuellement il ya 200 sessions de
recharge en cours et que dans la journée
il y avait eu six ans il existe deux
centres d'exploitation bouygues énergie
et services en france à toulouse et à
montigny le bretonneux ses
collaborateurs s'occupe des relations
avec les fournisseurs et des services
après l'installation de la borne
on a des missions extrêmement varié
entre le régler des problèmes de borne
donc laure et les dépouilles de bornes
régler des soucis avec le la supervision
assuré que le payement des sessions de
chercheurs fasse bien répondre à des
interrogations clients il ya des niveaux
ingénieurs autour de ce qu'il faut
vraiment connaître la bande de recharge
comprendre ce qu'elle nous dit concevoir
tout le système informatique
les nouveaux modèles de bornes sont
testés dans ce laboratoire c'est le cas
de la city charge un système conçu par
bouille énergie et services déployés sur
les lampadaires publics
ce petit boîtier mais vous voyez en fait
simule un simulateur de véhicules creek
si je fais le test sur cette bande
je passe un badge donc la borne
m'identifie elle m'autoriserai la porte
je branche mon vécu et écrit
et ensuite donc j'ai appuyé sur ce petit
bouton pour dire que le vide pour
simuler le dialogue du véhicule avec la
borne et maintenant je vais lancer la
charge pour utiliser ses infrastructures
l'usagé seront sur une application pour
identifier les bornes les plus proches
un corner on opère également d
des bornes de recharge publiques et à
deux bornes
effectivement quelques points de
recharge donc si je vais tuer je clique
sur la carte je vois la drees mais je
vois également du coup sûr quelle prise
je peux me recharger qu'elle puisse en
jeu pour recharger nous suivons
l'activité de développement des ventes
de voitures électriques donc c'est un
marché naissant
on espère que l'arrivée de 50 nouveaux
référence à l'année prochaine va
accélérer fortement ce marché qui ont
aujourd'hui à une croissance d'à peu
près 30% par an et qui devrait atteindre
50 à 63 cents de croissance où les ans
dans les prochaines années
avec cette augmentation exponentielle du
marché bouygues énergie et services
recherche de nouveaux collaborateurs
pour cette filière c'est une nouvelle
entreprise à saint quentin en yvelines
car what a rejoint coignières en juillet
2019 son activité transformer des
véhicules thermiques en véhicules
électriques une société en contrat avec
une entreprise de safari en tanzanie et
le groupe air france regardez sur ce
véhicule
on a retiré le moteur thermique c'est la
spécialité de l'entreprise car watts
remplacer le moteur thermique par un
système électrique une activité sur des
véhicules lourds comme sur cette voiture
de safari un moteur électrique donc
cette fois ci c'est un aimant permanent
avec son contrôleur moteur et tous les
auxiliaires nécessaires électrification
d'un véhicule pour alimenter ce moteur
électrique on a besoin d'une batterie
donc là je vous présente une batterie
issus de seconde vie une batterie
reconfigurer ce projet véhicule
électrique pour safari atteint déjà
plusieurs dizaines de commandes à venir
une phase d'industrialisation en
collaboration avec des entreprises en
tanzanie
il ya déjà quatre types
d'électrification qui sont partis sur
place qui viennent d arriver ils
viennent d'être dédouanés nos équipes
techniques vont aller sur place pour les
mettre en oeuvre à partir de novembre
né en 2014 car wattret utilisent des
batteries son principal fournisseur le
groupe renault avec des systèmes
électriques de véhicules zoé et kangoo
en juillet 2019 elle décide de
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
nous paraissait pertinent d'aller dans
ce que j'appellerais l'automotive valais
les compétences on les trouve localement
alors en plus des compétences humaines
issues il ya tout un tissu de petites
sociétés de la connectique de
mécanique de la transformation qui pour
nous est essentielle autre type de
production avec comme clients le groupe
air france l'équipement des véhicules
présents sur les pistes d'aéroports
comme les tapis pour mettre les bagages
dans les avions à partir de batteries
kangoo on part d'une batterie renault
kangoo deuxième vie qu'on va démonter
pour pouvoir récupérer une partie donc
des modèles la société comptera douze
salariés à la fin de l'année son chiffre
d'affaires va passer de 20000 euros fin
2010 8 à 500000 euros fin 2010 9
et si vous êtes intéressés par cette
activité cette entreprise va recruter
une quinzaine de collaborateurs en 2020
vous pouvez vous renseigner en
contactant eric blanchet le directeur de
l'entreprise éric points plancher @ car
wash one est la mobilité c'est aussi un
sujet pris en compte à l'estac à l'école
d'ingénieurs de montigny le bretonneux
cesser ces étudiants s'intéressent de
plus en plus à cette question nous avons
rencontré le responsable de filières de
l'établissement pour découvrir comment
lange et environnemental est pris en
compte dans la formation regarder
[Musique]
l'acca de filière aéronautique espace
automobiles et ferroviaires transport
guidé chaque filière contribuer dans son
spectre aux réflexions et aux
enseignements sur la mobilité verte
il ya une spécialisation
eco mobilité en 5e année d'abord à cause
des cours généraux de développement
durable donc sur le réchauffement
climatique sur l'écomobilité l'éco
conception
ça ce sont des cours qui sont donnés en
deuxième et troisième années pour tous
les étudiants
ensuite par par filière on va travailler
sur les moteurs électriques sur
l'hydrogène sur les moteurs à gaz
on va travailler sur les allègements
donc sur les matériaux alors sur un
double aspect comment j'allège et
comment j'utilise des des matériaux
naturels
[Musique]
il ya des gens qui voient ça de manière
assez éloignée et il ya une frange qui
est mon avis du président qui est tout à
fait croissante d'étudiants qui ont
repéré ça comme étant un enjeu essentiel
de la société donc il ya de plus en plus
d'étudiants qui ont des projets soient
de création d'entreprise qu'on
accompagne soit qui militent source à
des associations soit au sein soit
auprès de nous pour pro l'enseignement
pour développer ces aspects là et qu'ils
en font j'irais là le le le squelette ou
le hall orientations majeures de leur
future carrière
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]